[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
what is up what is good how you living
how you feeling it is time to get ready
for the nfl draft because i don't know
if you've looked at your calendar
it is april and we are four weeks away
from the nfl draft
28 days i got my man connor rogers with
me he's been getting me
ready for our big time draft show with
our special guest
and if you're watching right now you are
cramming you're either watching like i
am
on the br app or you are checking us out
on br youtube gridiron twitter
uh special shout out as always to rod
simmi and the regulators for the intro
music
and we have a great guest today mike
tannenbaum
former jets gm and dolphins evp will be
joining us shortly to go over
a bunch of the trades that happened what
could this mean he always has great info
excited to talk to him
and the theme today connor is workout
warriors that is our theme the guys that
have been jumping off the page in terms
of the pro day
if you are commenting on the app we will
get to your comments throughout the show
i'm looking
no april fool's jokes on this show i
promise
uh and then of course uh submit your
videos in the nfl draft community
uh and then we can play them in and if
we play them during the show you will be
getting a hoodie
gave away three last week hoping to give
away much
more this week connor i'm going to give
it to you in a second but first
let's go to an app video comment nicole
antonio
i think this is a question for you all
right
connor lefko with the theme being
workout warriors i have to know
what is your daily go-to workout routine
and to be clear i am not asking for
myself but i am asking for my boyfriend
this is a connor question it it fits the
theme of the show i'm no workout wonder
here let go but it's draft season i'm in
a nice groove got to get things going by
seven
uh keep it simple monday through
saturday sunday
take the day off and just split
everything up little chest on its own
bison tries shoulders on its own legs
twice a week is the secret so there you
go there's my workout wonder advice of
the week
nicole my uh my secret is um
i don't got none listen to connor connor
before we bring in uh
tatum bong because i would you want to
bring him on my my question for you
since our theme is workout wonders
compared to years past i know we're only
dealing with pro days what kind of
superior athletes do we have in this
draft compared to years past
really special and i think a lot of
people will look at it and they'll sit
there and they'll go you know oh these
don't count the same because it's not at
the combine and they're not laser times
and it's pro days
but i would argue a little bit left go
that these guys are just you know more
comfortable
right now they're in the atmosphere
they're used to the nerves aren't there
as much and they're ready to go they've
had more time to really just buckle down
and get ready for these pro days
it's a special group of athletes we're
going to talk through a ton of them
today wide receivers edge pass rushers
linebackers you name it but before we do
that like you said i'm excited to talk
trades here
with mike tannenbaum let's bring him on
it's not talking baseball i know
connor's upset because the mets uh
opening day got canceled sorry but let's
bring them in
former jets gm dolphins evp does great
stuff over at espn
mike tannenbaum mike welcome to the show
pal how you
doing how you feeling you know i'm a
former
pittsfield mets intern you know so we
could tie in opening day and
talk all the match you'd like to i know
connor would but that's why i'm here
mike
to get this back to the straight and
narrow let's just let's go right to the
trade that shook everything last week
uh dolphins go back eventually move back
up but the big note here
niners going third i saw that you were
in agreement with a few other people
this has to be for mac jones i saw you
saying there's a lot of comparisons to
matt ryan
do you still feel that way after if
you've had a few days to digest this and
talk to people
yeah absolutely yeah i spotted a handful
of people in around
the league and i felt strongly
beforehand and even more so now for a
number of reasons
first of all matt jones really processes
information
really quickly he's a better athlete
than people realize and i think the matt
ryan comparison
is really good i had a former head coach
yesterday compared to philip rivers
and i think it's notable guys that on
the same day that
both matt jones in tuscaloosa and justin
feels in ohio state we're working out
that kyle shanahan the head coach of the
49ers and john lynch dear gm
we're in tuscaloosa and you guys touched
on it a little bit it's still an unusual
off-season and the fact that they were
in
uh alabama not ohio state is meaningful
in my opinion
and i think their decision has been made
candidly you can't give up two
first-round pits and on third guys
and not know what you're doing so to me
they went down there to see him but i
think for them the hay is certainly in
the barn
connor i'm going to get to you in a
second but i want to get to this app
comment
and give it to mike jj09 this is the
dilemma that i think
draft fans are going through and they
set it out why are people
continuing to insist that mac jones is
going to be in the top
ten i would take trubisky over mac now
listen
this is a fan comment the the inner
workings of the nfl may go over their
head but
tenenbaum there's this thing that
happens when fans
look at mock drafts and they've been
looking at them for months
and they start here and they start
thinking oh this is where a guy is
supposed to go
that with mac jones specifically i think
people are having a hard time
thinking of him up there because they
haven't seen him up there in months what
do you think what's your take on that
yeah that's a really interesting point
and it's funny how
um the that no comment from
uh one of the fans is talking about
trubisky how about this over the last 10
years
five times a team has traded up into the
top three
to take a quarterback rg3 carson wentz
jared goff sam darnold and mitch
trubisky
and none of those five are still with
the team that traded up from or
i would say sam darwin's certainly
imminent so um
i think as it relates to jones guys like
he's
been a good player where he's been
mocked or
are obviously things that he can't
control but you certainly could say that
you know if tuatan below won five last
year um
and he had what the weapons he had
around him what mack jones did
which was more productive with less
weapons certainly
puts him in that conversation with the
top five and candy i would take him over
daniel jones who
just a couple years ago also won in that
part of the draft
last question for mike before i go to
connor so wait if you were a gm and you
saw that stat
about top five picks trading up and then
you were a gm
would you trade up for a quarterback or
seeing that would that scare you away
yeah i think what it does adam is it
just makes you double down on your
research in your preparation
you know going back uh over a decade ago
with uh
mark sanchez we had concerns about the
fact that he had
very little experience at usc and coach
parcells always talked about
in college football every 10 starts
quarterbacks you get discernibly better
with experience
and mark had 13 starts to sc and that
was a big concern
and what's unusual about mark sanchez is
he came in and played very well
took us to two championship games and
then had some struggles and
i would certainly want to know that
information about trading up for mack
jones but
what really has served me well in my
career guys is when you trade up and
give up the assets that you do
the character and the talent you have to
check every box and there's no doubt
that
mac jones has really tremendous
intangibles
that stat would make me i would say
perceive but i'm proceeding with even
more caution
conor uh we were talking before that
this entire week
has felt like justin fields i'm here
i'm great stop trash talking me it's
been like a very conflicting week
and the fact that the pro day was the
same day as mac jones
conor what did you take away from justin
fields pro day and just the conversation
at large
well i thought overall he obviously did
a good job now these are pro days as
mike knows really
well so how much can you really take
from it but obviously the scripted
workout was really good
we know he's a great athlete he goes out
there and runs a 4-4-4 which is just
a tremendous time for a quarterback a
big-bodied quarterback that can push the
ball down the field and he's really
accurate at all three levels so
we know the physical attributes are
there for justin fields now i hear a lot
of these different various rumors about
whatever you want to say about i don't
know character or
work ethic or anything like that
everybody i've talked to at ohio state
loves the guy believes the hard work is
there and that he's only going to get
better over time so i think it's been
a good week for justin fields now would
i be surprised if mac jones is drafted
ahead of him
i would not be surprised but that's not
what i would do i i think the sky
is really the limit i think the ceiling
with justin fields is special and i feel
the same way about trey lance who i
think is
under consideration to be the number
three overall pick as well
making for a really interesting
conversation so there's a lot of varying
opinions and i think a lot of teams are
definitely holding their cards really
really tight
but it goes to show you that when all is
said and done we're gonna have five
quarterbacks taken in the top eight of
this draft
um wow i think also when you factor in
that you have
carolina's sitting there at eight denver
sitting there at nine
uh we talked before who knows what
miami's thinking about doing at six
and tannenbaum i'm gonna go to you here
uh bugsy moogs asked this question
after the pro day results who do you
have the fins
taking at six from bugsy moogs
uh there was some talk that i saw mike
that people the dolphins they traded
back up to six because they want to get
either a chase or a devante smith
knowing that organization seeing that
they don't have a ton of holes in their
roster
what do you see for the fins at six i
think it's gonna be jamar chase from lsu
or kyle pitts the tight end from florida
and i think it's really going to be
whoever cincinnati doesn't take and i
know that sounds like joe burrows been
lobbing pretty hard for them to
draft jamar chase it the former lsu team
made f5 with cincinnati so
i think the other inflection point in
this draft is going to be at four
with atlanta where trey lance to me has
a ton
upside only played in one game this year
because of covid and north dakota state
just
only had one opponent but i think justin
fields and trey lance will definitely be
in the mix for
atlanta for again there could be a
surprise you guys already mentioned
carolina at eight could they come up
but i think miami clearly went from 12
to six gave up a one next year
for one of those high-end skill players
i have a question connor
from yeah go for mike mike you built
obviously those great new york jets
teams that
had the best offensive line in football
with the young quarterback behind them
do you find it interesting how much and
how often we talk about and i agree i
think it's going to happen with
cincinnati and miami they're looking at
skill players
but two teams that their offensive line
is incomplete this is a good offensive
line class especially a tackle
do you find it interesting that it seems
like those position positions just
aren't in consideration for either of
them right now
yeah it's a really fair point um i had
the good fortune my first time
as a gm first literally our first draft
we had two ones and we took to burger
shaw ferguson
left tackle from virginia and nick
mingle the 29 center from ohio state and
they were building blocks for
a number of good teams we had for over a
decade and look it's not the most
sexy pick and a lot of pizzazz but it is
the foundation for success
and you know show me a good team i'm
going to show you a good offensive line
so
certainly since 95 even miami at six
although i doubt it
they certainly will be discussing some
of those offensive linemen and
ironically some of these miami trades go
back to when we drafted laramie tunsil
in miami where he felt us because of
obviously what happened
when the draft started but penae suelle
there's a bunch of guys
christian darasaw slater uh from
northwestern
there's a number of frontline tackles
that could come in and start right away
yeah connor i'm always interested with
the falcons at four because two years
ago they took lidstrom and mcgary both
in the first round
are they worried about doing it again
but at the same point if you can build
the offensive line
i mean this is just football guaranteed
knowledge you're gonna be a lot better
conor i want to go to you here first
because my birds
my eagles are now at 12. uh
and i'm glad they got another first
round pick with the carson wentz trade
it should be
apparently three first round picks we'll
see how that goes
uh but at 12 what do you think is a
great pick for the eagles at 12 connor
honestly whoever falls out of the top
four blue chip kind of pass catchers
left go and you just heard mike say it
that jamar chase and kyle pitts
not going to be there you're not getting
that lucky and that's the risk you take
when you move that far back but
devonta smith or jaylen waddle becomes
really really interesting i think
they're a team that we've seen them
value speed in the past so maybe they go
with somebody that
is a little bit more polished than
devonta smith and i think people will
think
wow it's crazy for one of them to be
there but it's really not like we said
five quarterbacks probably going in the
top eight to ten picks couple offensive
tackles micah parsons might find his way
in there especially with detroit picking
in the top ten
i think the eagles got to be all over
these pass catchers if they
really really want to give jalen hurts a
chance
yeah as an eagles fan it's tough going
right after the cowboys
and then the giants but mike just as
someone that's been the front office
what is your read on howie and where do
you think howie roseman would be leaning
after trading back and sitting at 12.
yeah i think they clearly said that
jalen hurst is their guy at least for
this year
and they deserve a ton of credit in
terms of sitting there potentially with
three number one picks next year
assuming carson wins plays 35 or more
for the colts so i think
i agree with conor i think they'll come
out of this with a frontline skill
player and
i don't think kyle pitts will be there
especially after yesterday but
someone should fall to them um a good
skill player
and it's been unusual so far but i think
clearly that's the way the board's
setting up i think one of the most
interesting things to me if i could be a
fly on the wall of any of the 32 teams
is dallas because you know last year
they had a lot of holes in the offensive
line
i certainly thought that's the way they
were going to go and inexplicably
cd lamb sitting there and they take him
and i thought that was a reasonable
decision at the time
and let's just run this play one more
time what happens
you know pick a name jalen waddle let's
say kyle pitts is there for them
they are desperate for defensive players
but
if a top five blue chip offensive player
which is the last thing they need
from a cap roster construction you know
on a number of levels like what would
jerry jones do and i would be
fascinated to be a fly on the wall if
pits or waddle is there
and so is patrick certain you're right
like if if pitts for some reason the top
10 goes you know what we still don't
like drafting tight ends that early and
he's sitting there and he's like man
blake jarwin's not cutting it that
really could be interesting
mike i'm also curious so if we think
there's going to be quarterbacks going
one two three
let me just run through the top ten do
you think atlanta takes a quarterback
i do i think it's set up perfectly for
them if i'm arthur smith
and i'm going to be there for the next
10 years i i go in year one
i take a guy let him sit behind matt
ryan very similar to what kansas city
did a couple years ago with alex smith
and patrick mahomes so to me if they're
going to have that
justin fields trey lance debate okay
then you got cincinnati who they would
then have the
you know wide receiver offensive lineman
of their choosing then miami
detroit i would imagine they're going to
be sticking with goff and then it's
carolina denver
do you see teams trying to get in front
of eight in front of carolina to draft
that other quarterback or do you maybe
see it going to carolina there
yeah it's a great point i could see
detroit at seven being able to move back
and pick up additional assets because
and it could be new england let's say i
think chicago is too far away
coming that far up but you know could
you see a detroit new england trade
going from seven to fifteen i think that
certainly has to be in play
um i think jimmy garoppolo getting
traded on draft day
could factor into this as well so
there's a lot of variables but i think
carolina's search
kind of the floor of this discussion i
agree with what connor said a couple
minutes ago which is
i think we could see five quarterbacks
in the top eight now which eight teams
that is
i don't think that story's been written
yet
all right mike we're going to you
today's show is about workout warriors
take me to a private workout a
pro day that it's just etched in your
mind
you cannot believe what that guy did
yeah it was really darrell remus for us
where at his pro day
we knew that um there was no way we were
at 25
we trade up to 14. and this is going
back a number of years ago but the old
big east
that's where pitt was and there weren't
really any good uh receivers
in that year in the conference so
darrell declared late there wasn't a lot
of great tape on him not because he
wasn't great
but there weren't really any front line
receivers so it was really a great
incomplete and he blew it out as pro day
and uh you know we knew then and there
that for us to get him we were gonna
have to go up
and uh that was one of those moves that
certainly worked out and we were really
fortunate to get them
well tell me about the workout what was
the workout with rivas
that you were like i don't care who he
faced this is crazy to watch
you know if you ever met dorell he is a
really well built
thickly naturally strong guy like he you
know
sometimes guys that run fast or lean
like he's a straw like all you have to
do is shake his hand and you'll know
what i mean
so he's a strong guy but man was he fast
and could he change direction
and he really that's why he's a hall of
famer he had it all he had the ability
to get a half a yard away from you and
put his arm hands on you and it was over
but he also had the athletic confidence
to go and trail
and he had great recovery speed he could
sink his hips and change direction
he really had it all and after that
workout we were just convicted in hey
this is a guy we want to go up and get
um and clearly there was no way he was
going to be there where we were picking
other side of the coin uh you're
watching all these mock drafts and
you're seeing all these reports about
this
superb athlete comes out and works for
you and you're like
i just don't see you ended up being
right what was one of those situations
yeah i know there i would say there were
a few of those i would say a couple of
offensive linemen along the way that
you know when they lack foot quickness
it's over you know they can be strong
they can be tough
um you know one of the mistakes we made
candidly was anthony schlegel where we
we fell in love with him
and his intangibles we drafted him in
the third round from ohio state he had
transferred from air force
he just he did not work out great it was
a lesson learned because that translated
to like
him just being a very poor space player
um but there was a number of offensive
linemen along the way where
if you don't have foot quickness you you
can't play in the nfl there's too many
good
the athletic defensive lineman and
that's a very
like with it's a critical factor if you
don't have quick feet
there's nothing else really matters
to go to what you said earlier about
darrell rivas a cornerback
at a workout that just knocks your socks
off
we got that with patrick certain the
second this week
six two two oh eight four four forty ten
foot
eleven inch broad jump a 39 inch
vertical
18 reps of 225 and mike we have a
comment here from img baby 12
something that you talked about earlier
do you think the cowboys will draft
patrick certain if he's available at 10
tell me a little bit about the prospect
and then also this question
yeah absolute no-brainer you know so tan
is one of these players we just talked
about the royal reasons he he checks all
the boxes his dad played in the league
he's been someone that studied this
position for a long time
we see here make a really good play on
the ball
he is well built he has short area
quickness he has long speed
he's strong you can see it here forces a
pitch
um very athletic very competitive
great instincts and great
competitiveness so
in terms of a corner yet he has it all
he checks every box he should be a top
10 pick
um you know you can see a lot of these
plays now college football the you know
these
screens outside the numbers it puts a
huge emphasis
on tackling for corners which is
something coach belichick
talks about all the time and patrick
certain can do that he can play in any
system he has awareness
playing zone and instincts but he has
the athleticism and short area quickness
to play in man so he's not a scheme
specific corner has great instincts like
i said he's been around the game his
whole life and been
really well coached by coach saban so
i'd be really surprised
if he fell below 10. and with caleb
farley getting another back surgery you
would imagine it makes the
the priority on a premier corner even
more at the top of the draft
connor from the pro days that you've
seen this week workout warriors what
corners have jumped out to you
it's got to be him and uh jc horn i mean
when you look at it and then you talk
about obviously farley having some
questionable medical down the stretch
jc horn is somebody that has made this
conversation really interesting to
probably be the second cornerback off
the board i agree with mike that
it's certain show in the top ten and
then somebody's gonna be looking for
a physical corner that can press that
can run he's obviously
very very explosive he's a little too
physical at times especially with the
way the nfl rules are
but i think you can coach that out of
him the confidence is incredible
we know he's joe horn's son so he lives
and breathes football for a long time
now
jc horn is somebody to be really excited
about
i like these father-son combos it gives
me a lot of confidence on the kids
mike before i let you go i need to know
who is your draft crush who is the
player that you've been watching
and that when guys call you up you're
like have you seen this kid
who is your your draft crush right now
boy that's a good question there's so
many that uh i like you know i think
daraso from virginia tech because he
reminds me a little bit of uh
the brickish on ferguson he's sort of
like a quiet
steady a little bit under the radar you
know we're all these mocks with pine
soil who's a good player
but i think when it's all said and done
and we look back in five years and talk
about the class of 21.
i think he's going to be this
plug-and-play tackle that's steady quiet
he's really a good foot athlete with
long arms
i think he's your prototypical
prototypical left tackle
and not getting a lot of buzz and it
just seems like he's really comfortable
with that
awesome mike tannenbaum man thank you
for the time we're going to watch you on
espn i appreciate you dude
all right appreciate you guys having me
thank you thank you
phillies that felt good
uh connor garrison i haven't heard this
guy's name where is he
in terms of the tackle rankings that
mike just mentioned
i love him he's sitting sturdy at
offensive tackle number three left going
my 15th player overall
so i love that mike called that name out
because it's been a little bit of a
quiet process for him
i think when you look at it we know
about penne sewell we know
about rashaan slater that you got guys
that are getting love like vera tucker
that might play
guard and tevin jenkins but darasaw he's
a bit of a bully and you know i mean
when you hear somebody compared like
mike said to
brickishaw ferguson i think that's
really exciting darius got
much better from a starter in 2018 2019
2020 took his game
to a completely new level you saw him
going to climbing to the second level of
the field and burying linebackers when
we get to those b-rolls one day
on the draft it'll be uh it'll be a lot
of fun to watch he's a player that
excites me and
i think a team will look at him at right
tackle as well i think he has a lot of
versatility
um listening to you and mike talk about
five quarterbacks in the top eight makes
me realize number one
man the dolphins did great with that
trade to pick up all those picks and get
back to six which will likely get them
the number one player at
any position they want because they
believe in tua whether it's
tackle wide receiver shoot they could go
corner which they don't even need
because they got xavier howard and byron
jones but they have the pick of the
litter
and it also makes a little bit of sense
with the eagles because if you're the
eagles and you know that you don't want
one of those quarterbacks you can't get
zach wilson
well if five of the top eight are
quarterbacks
all the good players are getting pushed
down to you so it should be a very
interesting
it which quarterback do you think goes
last connor
honestly with all this buzz left go out
of those top five
i think it's gonna be justin fields i
think it's ridiculous he's my
quarterback three
i think it's absurd i think it's stupid
um you know
and even all those rumors that we
touched on earlier you know like i said
i asked
people that would know and it's not that
no it's not that he's not working hard
he actually he lifts and throws as much
as anyone you'll ever
see so i think it's just it's a lot of
nonsense
honestly quite frankly and just because
he's not a rah-rah guy we're used to
quarterback classes with
baker mayfield and joe burrow and you
love that about them it's exciting
justin fields isn't going to be on
twitter or doing commercials or
or the guy that's the loudest one in the
locker room but people like him
that's okay it's just that these things
these perceptions get taken to another
level and it's it's quite ridiculous now
with that being said to answer your
question i do think he'll be the fifth
quarterback off the board
and that might benefit a carolina or a
denver who already have pieces on their
offense that
that also might benefit justin fields in
the long run too
got a great comment here from a handsome
duck
said lefko is the biggest goober
thanks a handsome duck thanks for
watching what we're gonna do now is
we're breaking down
the best workout wonders from like the
last few weeks with pro days
and as connor came up the list there
were two main groups
wide receivers and then edge rushers and
linebackers
typically that makes sense when you're
talking about workout wonders
we do have an app video comment it is
our second one of the day
and it's got a little bit of a monster
mash feel let's take a look
hey connor and lefko i was just
wondering for
this year's wide receiver class there
are so many great talents they're
they all excel in their own individual
way so if you would do sort of a
frankenstein draft or you could
create the perfect receiver say jamar
chase's frame with jalen waddle speed
for example
what would your pick for that kind of
guy be thanks
all right connor work your mind i love
these questions
all right now let's get right to it he
he started off with the two obvious
jamar chase we're going body control
physicality so
right there okay that physicality jalen
waddle the speed
we know about that that's where it gets
a little more fun though devonte smith's
hands
perfect not dropping anything this wide
receiver now i'm gonna cheat a little
bit i'm gonna sneak kyle pitts into here
wingspan he just recorded the biggest
wingspan of the last 20 years for a
tight end left go
he's a small forward out there on the
football field
and then we'll go with uh rashad bateman
releases and routes
pro ready good to go and then rondell
moore's agility his three cone
was silly absolutely stupid we'll get to
him
isolated later so that right there is
your frankenstein pass catcher
can we talk about pitts because i don't
think we have him
on the rest of our workout warriors but
what he did yesterday
uh i kept seeing like when i when i went
on twitter
and the two names that were trending
were kyle pitts and dk metcalf
i was like oh wow he did one of those
days what did we see from kyle pitts
with the florida pro day
i mean when you look at him he's huge
right he's almost six foot six six foot
five five eighths 245 pounds
giant hands and like i said the wingspan
is the biggest recorded for a tight end
that we've seen in the last 20 years
and then he goes and runs a 4-4-4 left
going i don't even think it was
this perfect 40 for him i honestly think
he might be faster if you give him
another attempt out there or you record
his
gps field speed so he catches everything
he's getting bigger and stronger which
is going to help him as an
inline blocker or even a blocker out
wide
we know he can jump and hang in the air
forever because that's all
on film already there wasn't much kyle
pitts had to do but now when you see it
on paper that he has
really good wide receiver athleticism
with tight end size and
arms that could just reach up and touch
the goal post he's a good one man it's
it's really really exciting
if he was listed kyle pitts as a wide
receiver and not a tight end
how would he be if seen in this class i
think for
me he would just be behind jamar chase
and then jalen waddle
as wide receiver three just based on the
pass catching skills alone which
goes to show you because i'm so high on
those guys they're both top ten players
for me
just how special he is i mean jamar
chase is better than anybody in last
year's class and we know how good that
class was with cd lamb who was my
favorite of those three
henry rugs goes first jamar chase is
better than any of them there's no
overthinking this player he's out there
beating
nfl starting cornerbacks as a 19 year
old the tracking
the hands the physicality now the speed
he went out and ran up 438 yesterday
when everyone's like well we don't know
if he can run
and then he jumps through the roof 41
inch vertical an 11 foot broad jump
these are elite numbers with elite
production for a 19 year old at the time
that was the number one wide receiver
on a national championship team there's
no questions
with jamar chase and that's why he's
probably going number five overall to be
reunited with joe burton
when i saw that joe burrow was lobbying
the bengals to draft his old wide
receiver
and then i started going man if they get
him some time
with some offensive line and he has t
higgins and jamar chase i was like
that's the trio for like the next
five ten years man it's cool when he's
like trying to get his former teammate i
love that
so jamar chase clearly are number one
now sounds like it
clear clearly number one sitting there
uh nice and sturdy at
player number six on the big board and
he's not going any further down
um okay so likely he's either going to
cincinnati at five
or miami at six is kind of what it
sounds like
another wide receiver that is a workout
warrior
um i keep seeing clips of him in terms
of
one-on-one shadow drills dusting people
how did rondell moore do at his pro day
for your second workout warrior
so an interesting start when he comes in
at five foot seven and everyone's like
well i thought
he was five foot nine and it's like okay
well how does it matter we know he's
small we know he's a slot only
and we know he's one of the most agile
little compact strong receivers we've
seen in this class with top flight
acceleration so when you look at rondale
moore lepco
it's not the five foot seven that jumps
out
six foot it's the six six eights recon
elite agility numbers and i don't care
that he's small he's not
tiny he's just compact he's short he's
muscled up
once again testing numbers are really
really good you're going to have to get
creative you've got to find a way to get
the ball in this guy's hands
jet sweeps screens underneath routes
drag routes just find a way to clear out
space
and let him work but rondale moore i'm
really excited about him it's all about
staying healthy i know it's been a
problem the last two years if he could
stay healthy
he's a legitimate difference maker and
one of those home run kind of guys
yeah height is something that prevents
you from going in the first round but it
does not prevent you from going in the
league
we are seeing look at the market for
adam humphries in free agency the last
few years
just somebody that can work the slot and
is all about agility and all about
quickness
there's two different games there's
outside receiver and there's interior
receiver
and it looks like rondelle moore has all
the tools for that
another wide receiver that you thought
was a workout warrior had a
monster vertical leap my first question
is who
and my second question is what do you
learn from somebody with a crazy
vertical
well it's josh madder babe from illinois
the transfer from usc and
i mean he did this in high school so did
it shock anyone not necessarily but you
also see it on film
a 46 and a half inch vertical leap left
go
it just doesn't get better than that i
don't even know if a lot of places go
up that high they probably had to find a
custom i've never seen that number
and the quarterback play
was not great for him so the numbers
might not really
jump out at you but when they just threw
the ball up to him and gave him a chance
he's a big body target a target big
catch radius
we know he can hang in the air i think
he'll have a role in the nfl as a red
zone player
i think the best is yet to come for him
it might have started out a little bit
rocky having a transfer
and once again not going to a program
where you're going to put up these crazy
pass catching numbers
but the workout's good i like the film
and if somebody drafts him and says hey
you'll be our number four
number five wide receiver out of the
gate but when we get in that red area in
the 20
look out for the jump ball it's going to
you
uh so it's pronounced a matter baby
you nailed it love it uh also was he the
one
that the video where it looked like he
was floating in high school
on the vertical leap pad was that him
i i think so it was recorded as 47
inches
in high school which is just hilarious
so
and then you know obviously it gets
bigger stronger and still maintains it
at 46 and a half
it's just absurd and you could see him
work on the outside of the field and you
know underneath of course once i
i said it again a big muscled up frame
that could take hits but also a jump
ball player that dbs are gonna have a
lot of problems with in isolated
situations which you'll see perfect
example
right there body control keep the feet
in bounds perfect catch
i'll tell you what illinois has been one
of those universities too where they
don't consistently put out players but
when they do they're typically
high-end athletes remember brandon lloyd
out of illinois
stretched jumper all the time i think
vontae davis went to illinois as well
i think i may have been wrong
i'll look it up it's okay we'll roll
with it yeah exactly
okay you have one more wide receiver
give me a guy that
most people that are in the comments
right now have not heard
but whose pro day and performance got
him a lot of attention
sure well we did the davis mills
breakdown on the quarterback show but
now let's talk about his wide receiver
in simi
and of course when you look on paper
that he's six foot four
222 and i'm not trying to give you bad
jj arsega white side vibes here left
though he's a little bit different of a
player
he's a really really tall wide receiver
but what jumped out to me
you see the straight line speed there of
course that is good for six four two
twenty two the straight line speed
four four two that is very fast for that
size
but to go with a six eight six three
cone he's got a lot of agility and
that's gonna help with this
route running that's going to help after
the catch he's not just this tall
lumbering stiff kind of player he's a
really really good athlete that once
again
the best is yet to come i don't think
he's getting any love i don't see him as
a top 10 wide receiver on any list or
any rankings or
anything like that not a player
mentioned to be drafted in the first two
rounds but
everything is right there for you some
monster games on tape
the size the speed but the agility is
the one that shocked me and had him
had to put him in our workout wonders
list yeah i know that you warned me
ahead of time
but the j.j ortega white side just from
seeing the stanford cardinal just got me
going
we have an app comment here by the way
the app comments have been good
papo's i saying she's saying yes
lefkovanti davis did go
to illinois i feel good about that one
uh app comment this is from the bread
man 10.
with the giant signing golliday and
jackson
do they go with parsons if he's there so
parsons would be micah parsons uh what
do you think about this question the
giants are sitting at 11
right behind dallas it's a great
question because there's not a lot of
blue chip defensive players in this
draft and when you look at the giants
they've been aggressive to say hey
let's go get daniel jones some help so
do you look at micah parsons
they have a need at linebacker and dave
gellman has invested early in linebacker
in the past it took shaq thompson in the
first round when he was the gm of the
panthers
micah parsons he's going to go earlier
than the top you know that late
first round kind of range i want to talk
about a workout wonder and micah parsons
four three nine forty ten foot
six broad jump six nine six three cone
elite linebacker numbers where
i wanna say yes to this question that
he's in consideration but one big thing
has to come into play here for me lefko
do they think they can also use him as
an edge rusher i think he has the traits
we the effective blitzing is on tape but
i'm talking hand in the dirt at times
i'm passing down edge rusher
can he do that that's something a lot of
teams thought jalen smith thought he
could do in that draft that's why
before he got hurt he was a projected
top 10 pick so for micah parsons
wondering
the same thing the giants need edge pass
rush help you did a good job you went
out and signed a dory jackson
you have james bradbury you have good
corner play you have a lot of money and
resources tied up in the front four
but do you need somebody in the middle
of the field absolutely my question
is is it worth taking a linebacker with
the top 15 pick that's something they're
going to have to answer
they still have a lot of questions on
the offensive line specifically
at the guard spots rashaan slater may be
there that makes a little more sense to
me but with dave gettleman's history
the need on their defense he has to be
at least
on the board and in consideration for
them in that spot
and i'm looking to see if he'd be
available i don't know if detroit
goes with a linebacker that early just
because they have done it in the past
and their fan base for members guys like
ernie sims
carolina seems to be very quarterback
focused as well as denver at eight and
nine
and then you get to dallas and they
already have so much invested in their
young linebacker core
uh that he might be there at 11 for the
new york giants and if
you end up getting the first defensive
player taken
at 11. usually that guy ends up being
pretty good i think a lot of teams are
also seemingly afraid of taking
cornerbacks so you talked there about
micah parsons
uh what you mentioned edge did you talk
about jalen phillips at all for the
giants if they don't go micah parsons at
the edge
i did not but i'm glad you brought it up
because i would like to i think with
jalen phillips he's a top 15 pick if
teams are okay with his medicals and
we've talked about it on this show
before
i had to transfer him from ucla at one
point he medically retired
because of the concussion history there
comes back
gets his footing in miami with kind of a
year away from full football
comes back to the field in 2020 and he's
the superstar that we thought he would
be
coming out of high school and you want
to talk about numbers again here for
jalen phillips
he checks all the box at the position
and the giants need something at edge
rusher six
five a little bigger than six five two
sixty he reminds me of ziggy ansa left
go that kind of athleticism
four five six forty a seven three cone
36 inch vertical
people look at those numbers go well
they're not as impressive as the ones
you said for all these other guys
yeah but he's six foot six 260 pounds
he's a huge human
moving like that he could bend and turn
the corner so i think he should be the
giants picket 11 if you're
okay with those medicals that's a huge
huge question mark but
he is the most talented pass rusher in
this draft
by a mile but is he the top pass rusher
there's a big difference right there's a
lot of things you need to do behind the
scenes to make sure
connor so a lot of scouts front office
guys go to penn state's pro day
and they're there to watch micah parsons
who puts up those numbers that you
mentioned
a 439 40 a 696 cone
insane but i'm looking at your notes
here
and apparently one of the workout
warriors happened there as well so
they're all there for micah parsons
who else caught their eye yeah jason
away the edge pass rusher from penn
state
he is one of the most polarizing players
in this strap left go what if i told you
the first part that he didn't have a
sack in 2020. you got to go back to 2019
to find these plays
where he gets after the quarterback but
then what if i told you at 257 pounds
he runs a sub 440 with a 439
jumps 10 foot six inches broad which is
just insane
and a 6963 cone which to me is the most
important testing number of an edge
rusher because it's that agility along
with a 10 yard split you want to see
that get off so
this is the ultimate test left go of
production
versus traits and athleticism how will
teams value it
we've seen them in the past reach for
these guys and miss we've also seen them
be rewarded i think montez sweat and
daniel hunter come to mind to me as guys
that
great size great athleticism might not
wow you a ton in the box score
throughout their college career
is o-way the next one i have some
questions about his long-term projection
but man the workout just couldn't have
been better
nearly a 40-inch vertical an 11-foot
2-inch bra
jump yeah those guys and we've seen a
few of them out of penn state
who who what was the defense of lyman's
name out of penn state a few years ago
that was very similar to this in terms
of the athletic profile
i think the bills drafted them
well we had the bills uh take aaron
maben a long time ago that's the guy
just that's the guy freakshow
athleticism and that's a good example of
one that did not pan out so
you penn state it's ridiculous what they
do in the weight room
every year i you know if i'm gonna have
to run this 40 for the show can i go to
penn state for four weeks and maybe come
back
sub five speed what about we're going to
stay with the edge workout warriors
arrival of penn state michigan i see in
your notes here that there was a workout
warrior there what was his name
yeah quitty pay you know six foot two uh
really stocky kind of build six foot two
over 260 pounds
now unfortunately for quittipe he did
have a tight hamstring i believe during
his workout so
we didn't get to see the full show we
got the four five four
forty that's good speed 36 bench reps i
mean
this dude is a unit an absolute tank
they
love his work ethic at michigan let me
get that off the top because a lot of
people say hey he's raw in his pass rush
plan
he won't fail for lack of trying and
effort so he's a good investment you see
the pop there
against i believe indiana they had a
rough day against him
now lefko what i want to talk about with
cody pay is he didn't get to do it
because he did get hurt
this man is supposedly recorded
the most legendary three cone for an
edge pass rusher
and there's reported times at 637 the
video is out there on the internet so
you can time it yourself
we've never had a three cone in this
stratosphere for an edge pass rusher i
think the best one is usually like the
six
seven so if you don't believe me that's
okay
because i didn't believe it when i read
the feldman freaks article over the
summer
but quiddy does have the video it's
online just insane movement ability
insane agility for that size
it's really impressive i mean
that's like up there with top wide
receivers
i mean it's it's quicker than rom dale
moore who i thought was the most agile
player in this whole testing
at five seven i mean buster screen
ran the third fastest three-cone drill
and he's a cornerback
and he ran a 6-4-4 and you're telling me
this kid ran a 6-3
yeah he's teleporting essentially from
cone to cone is what he has to be doing
but if you're watching this show i
promise at the end of it google quitty
pay you can watch the video on twitter
it is amazing
and it is p-a-y-e for people listening
uh
it's a hundred percent because he's
wearing a michigan jersey but i'm
watching him
going looks like a brandon graham kind
of guy to me
low center of gravity not the biggest
guy in the world but just hustle
effort all the time uh one last guy you
got for us in terms of the workout
warriors defensive side
kentucky linebacker is it jameen davis
yeah jamin davis yep yeah absolutely i
think
this is the this is the riser of the
draft right now and and the tape is very
good i think he's very good against the
run
sideline to sideline speed good range i
think he will develop a lot as a cover
backer as well
all the tools are there and the workout
was very good four four 140
42 inch vertical for a linebacker left
go that is
absolutely nuts he is jumping through
the ceiling at that size and
he's got good size i'll say it right now
for him he's going probably in the first
round
you feel pretty good about that and this
is a name that if you brought it up
three months ago
nobody would think that so a big riser
for davis
um that's i love to see that
are you ready for app comment
rapid fire q and a let's do it
okay we're going to first start off
we're going to try and go rapid fire e
but we're going to start off with a
video comment from m costa 69 let's
check it out
my draft question what quarterback
between trask monde and mills
turns out to be the better nfl
quarterback
thank you you're welcome
connor go i just love the vibes of that
question i mean
where was that question asked wow it's
tough
you know i'm gonna say trask i think
will be a long-term backup
i'm gonna say monde has the biggest
ceiling
so i'm gonna throw the dart out there
that
monde has the biggest ceiling and i'll
go with him but
for pure evaluation trask is the safer
player
you're right though when you're dealing
with these guys if you go with the guy
with the highest ceiling and he hits it
you cover your ass which is really well
done by you okay rapid fire questions
next one
put them on the screen it is serious fan
120 the falcons seem to be the biggest
question mark of the draft what do you
think they do connor go
i think they trade the pick and i know
mike tannenbaum said he thinks they take
a quarterback arthur smith looked super
excited watching justin fields it's a
smart move i agree
so i hope they take justin fields and
let him sit behind matt ryan
but right now i'm leaning about 60
percent that they trade this pick
next question is coming in from m
billock 30 who was the draft sleeper
for surprise first round pick
yeah i just gave it to you it's got to
be jamin davis right now i think that's
the one
that really jumps out to me and maybe
one more would be tevin jenkins
the uh the offensive tackle from
oklahoma state
rapid fire follow-up question uh who
would be the quarterback
that sneaks into the end of the first
round if one does go in the end of the
first round
i'll ask richard head's question second
okay uh richard head who has been the
biggest faller in this year's draft
no oh it hurts but
it's greg rousseau from miami uh you're
talking about testing that is
below the 20th percentile for a player
that before you opted out was in the top
10 of every single summer mock draft yes
there are sickos like me that read
summer mock traps 10 months ahead
before the draft so a tough fall for
gregory rousseau who
did not play and then did not test well
at all
is there any chance it's an orlando
brown junior situation where the testing
isn't great but
the tape is what really matters yes left
go i did not drop him
to i've seen people say day three i've
seen people say round three
uh i'm not there i think he is he's a
top 75 pick he's a really hard worker
where he's just getting better i would
bet on him in the second round i'm okay
with that
learn from past years remember when that
happened to orlando brown and now he's
like a fragile killed him for it and i
absolutely huge miss for me loved the
film hated the testing
dropped him way too far you learned your
lesson the hard way
uh next one up this one's coming from
tom ross
oh excuse me dylan nikki who are the
most oh what are the most shocking
rumors you're hearing right now conor
what are the shockers
i mean i think we talked about this on
the first show with andrew whitworth
rashaan slater could be the first
offensive lineman off the board so i
hope you got those bets in why it was
plus 400 because that's pretty juicy
odds you gotta like that a lot
i think shocking rumors to me left go
not but it's so obvious and maybe people
are tired of hearing of it
i'm not buying that mac jones is going
third overall i'm not
i think it's trey lance i think they
have the perfect infrastructure in place
for trey lance to go
they're keeping jimmy g i don't think
they're trading them maybe i'll be wrong
about that too come draft weekend
i think jimmy gio going to camp as the
starter you have trey lance behind him
i can't see kyle shanahan giving up
three first-round picks
for mac jones and if he does we're gonna
have a conversation on that draft desk
so then quick follow-up before the last
question why
why all this mac jones smoke screen
because oh well because they're probably
doing a good job of fooling everyone
and number two everybody you talk to in
the nfl is just
gushing about mac jones uh it's the the
personality getting the ball out the
ball placement all of these different
things but
uh i i don't care necessarily about
those things i think justin fields and
trey lance are better quarterbacks
i think kyle shanahan's offense has been
limited by
guys like the kirk cousins of the world
or
love matt ryan but there's still limited
things you can do in that offense jimmy
g
limited offense there's no limitations
of what you can draw
up with trey lance or justin fields
last rapid fire question let's fill up
the screen
with the question what about how do you
say his name
eamonn ross saint brown among ross st
brown
i think you nailed it the first time
eamon ron saint brown i believe he is
related to
equinemia saint brown nobody's talked
about this guy
i get there's some other great receivers
out there but come on
man i mean listen you gotta
you know be careful where you get your
draft info from he's 62 overall for me
that's a really good wide receiver in
this class i think
he's one of the better jump ball wide
receivers it's a physical profile it's a
go up and win the football pretty tough
player after the catch but he does his
best work
in the middle of the field and in the
red zone and i think people will be
talking about him on that second night
of the draft and he's in my top 10 wide
receivers of this great class
um should be interesting is he a debated
prospect for you or you think you're
pretty confident in him
no i feel pretty good about it i don't
think you have to overthink him too much
well there are a lot of draft picks that
people are debating
the most debated prospects and that is
going to be our theme
next week so we gave you eight workout
warriors a little breakdown of the
trades with
mike tannenbaum thanks so much for him
joining us
every thursday live one o'clock here on
the app
be our gridiron twitter youtube and then
of course
getting pushed out on the left co show
as a podcast and then
also make sure that you guys send in
your video comments to the br
draft stream we pick three every week
those three that get played
get a hoodie and we are now four weeks
away
from the nfl draft conor any farewell
message before we get out of here today
i mean talking to mike t was awesome
obviously somebody that's built
successful football teams that i watched
when i was in high school so i think for
me that was pretty cool
and next week's going to be a lot of fun
left but what is better about the draft
than debating prospects
dk metcalf was debated derrick henry
was debated justin herbert
was debated the debates can be fun
lamar's remember lamar jackson baker
mayfield
all of them it's josh allen it's always
crazy and we're going to have the
biggest names next week for connor
rogers i am the l-e-f-k-o-e
man to everybody that watched we
appreciate you and we will see you next
week
one o'clock easter have a good week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign